let's forget all about the
[Music]
wine I've been going through some kind
of personal uh Rebellion I guess with
myself and uh I was trying to find
myself and I didn't quite know where I
where I was or where I wanted to go
[Music]
go let's forget all about the whne and
crying let's think about
living we just need to get out of
town before we catch another the beat
down
beat
[Music]
down yeah
beat
down down
[Music]
let's forget all about the whining
crying let's think about
living we just need to get out of town
before catch another beat down
[Music]
yeah you come with me please
oh you
see life too
short everything's been
sweet come
me it's going to be so
[Music]
nice won't ever
one I never come back
[Music]
yeah yeah
yeah forget all about the wine and
C here comes to Soul here comes to Soul
R dry
Let's Get It On
[Music]
[Applause]